So, me and the whole
bridal party
were roommates freshman year,
and everyone said I was going to
be the first one to get married.
And now I'm the only one
who's not, which is crazy.
It's crazy.
Please stop. Please stop.
I can't do this anymore.
There's more than
one type of Latino.
And I'm not going to fulfill
some stereotype
just to make somebody happy.
I'm sorry.
Hey, man, aren't you
the jaguar from Narcos?
Oh yes, I am.
Don't lie to me.
Sex is a very
important decision.
How are you defining sex?
What if there's two men
or two women?
How would you define sex with
multiple simultaneous partners,
or what if somebody's undergone
genital reconstruction
or is intersex?
He is just so, "Mm,"
and you're more like,
"Mm," you know?
Does that make sense?
Am I delicate?
You just decanted white wine.
It needs to breathe.
Back in the day, ese,
we had to call people like this.
Damn. That's what's up.
Hey,
What do you say to that?
Hey, get back here.
I'm not done. I'm not.
Did I say I was
done?